Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are exploring the
question is it ever okay
to kill someone?
Whoa.
Yeah, gettin' real.
And if so, are we ready,
willing and able to do it?
Yes and we're going to
be, yeah, I said yes.
I wasn't saying yes like
I'm ready to kill somebody.
No spoilers, I'm just saying yes,
that is what we're talking about.
We're talking about ethical conundrums.
That's a great word, conundrum.
Dilemmas.
Conundrums, and some classic, some maybe
that you'd never considered
before so putting ourselves
in a situation where we
have to make a decision
that may result in someone's death
and how do we go about
navigating that ethically.
Mm.
And comedically of course.
You know what, there's
something I've been wanting
to share and I think this is
the perfect place to share it,
something that happened to me.
Link listen,
hey dude, this is a safe space for you.
Thank you.
The round table of dim
lighting is a safe space.
Well, I've been wanting
to tell you about this
thing that happened to me
and I do think I can frame
it as an ethical dilemma.
Well then you should.
It's for me,
should I have taken action?
Oh.
Or for the person who did it to me,
was it right for them to do it?
Whoa, I'm intrigued.
Or wrong.
Or I think third option,
was it just creepy,
weird, odd, or uncalled for?
Okay.
Now I will say up top
this is a massage story.
Oh gosh.
I mean if you had
to think about the one
thing, the through line
of Ear Biscuits, I don't know
how you think of Ear Biscuits,
dear Ear Biscuiteer.
Yeah, couple of douches--
Listener.
Talking about massages.
But we do talk about massages a lot.
Hopefully you've had your first massage.
Really this is all just a plan to get you
if you've never been massaged--
You talked about massage last episode.
I did, yeah, I thought
that's why you were--
Man massage.
Well, I will say, well I won't say.
I was about to say
something I ain't gonna say.
You can say anything you want to.
For the sake of--
It's a safe space.
Safe space?
Yeah.
So I went in for a massage
and you know, the place that I go to,
ever since the pregnant
woman had the baby,
she never came back and she was amazing.
She's massaging that baby now.
She was the--
That baby's gettin'
all the massages.
She was like
the best masseuse I've ever had.
And she was like full plump pregnant.
Interesting, your masseuse was pregnant
and my trainer was pregnant.
Yeah.
My fitness trainer was pregnant.
Did she have the baby?
She's due any day now.
Well she'll never come back probably.
You think so, she's gonna
be training that baby now.
You can come back from having a baby.
I'm not saying you
can't, I'm just saying--
Oh she's planning on it.
Oh she's planning on it?
She's got it all planned out, yes.
I thought my masseuse did too
but then it's been almost a year now
and she's not coming back.
I think she moved.
Maybe she got a new, maybe she got a new--
It's not about the baby.
A new vocation.
Well she was perfect at
this, it was her gifting.
Hmm.
Maybe she's kneading dough now.
So now it's kinda like--
She works at a bakery.
It's kind of a crap shoot when I go there,
I'm like I want a deep tissue massage.
I want someone who can do that
and I lay down like normal.
Which is what, face up?
Well I start face down.
They tell you to start face down.
Yeah I know.
And then halfway through,
you roll over and you face up.
Right, yep.
That has nothing to do with this.
Yeah.
I'm face down.
I got my head into the donut.
And I'm starting to get this
massage in the back area
and everything's fine,
I'm evaluating is this
gonna be a good massage
and I'm like ,
it could be more pressure.
So you gotta ask for more pressure.
But then the pressure
increased a little bit
and as the hands move
up around the shoulders,
I start to notice that
the hands are traveling
in kind of an unexpected--
Pattern?
There's an unexpected
quality to the traveling
of the hands and I just, I
couldn't put my finger on it.
Oh.
Like the way that
my hands are moving, the way
that the hands are moving
on my back and then as the hands get--
Like a hand from two different people
or what do you mean?
I can't tell you because--
They're moving together,
like everything is in sequence?
No it was just a weird feeling.
I'm interested in what's happening here.
And then as the hands get
up around my shoulder area--
You realize--
It starts to feel,
the feeling is not any different
than how it's been feeling
and only slightly different
than a normal massage.
What?
But then all of a sudden
I hear this weird noise,
like a suction kind of a noise.
And it's like, and then
I realize that the skin
on the hands are sticking to
my body a little bit like--
Like Spider-Man.
Yeah, it was like--
Like Spider--
Yes.
Spider-Man's giving you
a massage.
It was like Spider-Man.
I was a skyscraper and Spider-Man
was giving the building
a massage and it was me.
And then she gets into
it a little bit more
and I hear some popping.
And some stretching.
What?
And I realize this masseuse
has on latex gloves.
Okay, see okay.
All right now I understand,
I was so confused.
Hold on but--
Once I realized--
Latex gloves
will still slide with massage oil.
Yeah when massage, right,
that's why I couldn't tell
at first but then when
they got right up there
by my ears, based on the sound,
I could tell it was latex
skin, it was gloves.
Interesting.
And then I'm like
what is going on?
You think this woman
does this for everyone
or she judged you, this
is definitely a glover.
This guy's definitely a glover.
Might have scabies.
We went to grade school with a girl
whose last name was Glover.
Remember that?
I wonder where that originated
from, the first Glover.
Were they people who made gloves?
Almost assuredly yes.
Right, latex gloves for masseuses.
Yeah.
And at this point I'm like--
Or maybe they're just a good
lover and it was shortened.
I'll just tell you that I
decided not to say anything,
but I was trying to figure out
am I gonna say something like--
Ah, gloves, huh?
Yeah.
Are those gloves or--
Your hand's really cold.
They're blue?
Is the skin comin' off your hands?
Were they blue?
I didn't look.
My hands were, I just said
my eyes, my hands, my feet.
My face was in the donut.
Right.
It's all speculation.
And so--
Could be dish hands.
If it was a fabulous massage
it probably would have overcome the fact
that there was latex involved.
But yeah, but it was
just an average massage
so I think that made it a little worse.
This is a weird--
It did not make it horrible,
it made it weird.
And I'm thinking yeah, is it me?
Is there something about--
No, it's weird.
Or is it her?
I think it's weird.
I know the place that you go, right.
Yeah, it's a chain.
It's a chain
that's like known and respected,
it's not some seedy place.
No.
I assume that there's
some sort of contract
that you have to sign--
There's like eight
or nine masseuses, they're
probably all trained
under the same regimen.
But I think part of that has to be--
The gloves is weird.
If you're gonna elect
to wear gloves and if it's not about me--
You should say it.
Then maybe it's about her.
Maybe it's--
I wear gloves.
Because doing this so long
has made my hands really rough
and your hands dry out
and then it makes for
an unpleasant experience for
the person getting a massage
if your hands are like, I
had a massage one time--
I seriously doubt that's the reason.
I had a massage one time
from a man actually.
A rough-handed man?
And he had rough hands
and it almost felt like
I was gettin' scratched
if certain parts of his
hand went along my surface.
Okay I understand that can happen
but I assume that--
I do think that
that could happen.
It's hygiene thing.
I think this person is like--
Or if they have an open wound.
Sir, I don't like to touch,
I don't like to touch people's skin.
I'm sorry I'm in the wrong
career but here we are.
If you go in the room and
you're like all right,
let's do this and you see the person,
they got a lot of bacne or
open wounds on their back,
first of all don't go to a masseuse,
just let yourself heal, brother.
I think I respect the fact
that they could choose
to put on gloves but it wasn't me,
I got nothing at the time at least
that's gonna make 'em pause but
so I think it has to do
with something like that
and again, I just feel like
you need to say something.
I just wanna let you know I'm
gonna be wearing latex gloves
but I do this a lot and I do not,
I can confidently say it's not
gonna compromise your experience.
Yeah yeah yeah.
But if you'd like to--
Nothing against you, I
do this with everyone.
Yeah the fact that she didn't say anything
I think was, I think we're
dealing with an ethical conundrum
and I think she failed.
But what about--
So I killed her.
I murdered her.
What should you have done?
You think you should have
said something about it?
Well I think when I left and I paid
and that's when you put the tip out there.
You put it in a little
glove and put like a dollar
in a glove.
Just put a glove as the tip.
Like she's gonna need this.
It's not used.
No, the person at the counter
was like, "How was it?"
And I was like, "Fine."
There were gloves.
But I shouldn't have said, well,
I was a little taken aback by the fact
that there were gloves involved.
I mean was this gonna turn
into some sort of exam?
I think you could say that the next time.
Now if you go back--
I haven't been back since then.
I haven't gotten a massage
since the latex glove massage.
How long ago was this?
And for the record,
there was not an exam involved.
But for a few minutes
there, I didn't know.
Right, how long ago was this?
Could have been an internal massage.
Yeah, I'm familiar.
This has been,
it's been three months, man.
Mr. Massage hasn't had a
massage in three months
because of the gloves?
It's rurnt me.
Go somewhere else
or call and say, "Hey, there
was this glove situation
"last time I was there
"and I wanna know is that still happening
"and maybe I can get somebody
who doesn't wear gloves."
I've had a lot of people there--
You're trying to find--
And this is the first time.
You're trying to find your replacement
for the lady that's
now massaging the baby.
I'm actually, I'm not
going to this place anymore
because they're always booked up.
Oh okay.
You know how my schedule is, man.
I wake up that morning,
I'm like oh yeah today,
I have a window of time, I
could probably get a massage.
They never can get me in there, you know.
I think I might need to
call and be like listen,
can I get a massage today,
I know it's last minute
but I'm willing to take the latex lady.
That may be the world I'm livin' in now.
Yeah.
I'm unhappy.
Go on--
Look at the Yelp reviews
and see if anybody's
talked about the gloves.
'Cause they may, three months later--
Would you have stopped the moment--
No.
11 minutes into the massage?
I didn't.
In fact, even when someone tells me okay--
I'm gonna be having gloves.
What kind of pressure
would you like and I say, "Hard."
And then I say, "I'll
tell ya if it's too much."
You don't.
And then I, however, during
my Palm Springs massage,
it got to a point where
I thought I was going to,
I was beginning to whimper and I thought
that I may begin weeping.
And at that point I was like,
"That's a little too intense."
I did say that and he let up a little bit.
He was squeezing this muscle
right here in the shoulder,
like that band.
Oh gosh.
Yeah.
And he was like getting
his fingers under it and around it.
Oh wow.
Ugh.
Just felt so good in the
wrong, the right ways
and bad in the right
ways, I don't know but,
yeah, I had to tell him to
let up 'cause I was like
I'm gonna start crying
and I don't wanna do that.
But it takes a lot for
me to tell you to stop,
so I'm definitely, rubber
gloves I would say nothing.
If she would have done that
to me, I'd have been like--
You're gonna have to take the gloves off.
You're gonna have to go
clubless for this one.
It's much weirder to say
something about the gloves like,
she touches you and you
hear something and then,
you pull your head up
and turn around and look.
Oh you got gloves on, huh?
She probably would have
explained herself.
You're glovin' it.
Okay well we have more--
We both failed
at that--
More difficult,
we've got more difficult
ethical conundrums
that we'll be getting to.
But first we do wanna let you know
that you can pick up Link's shirt.
It's got Cotton Candy Randy on it.
It's tie-dye, it looks a little evil,
he's busting out of it.
Not Link but Cotton Candy Randy.
It's sweet, check it out.
It says hi daddies on it.
It's available along
with many other things
including these mugs at Mythical.store.
Go to Mythical.store just
to look at the pictures
if for no other reason.
Yeah just have fun.
Just have fun over there.
Just surf.
When's the last time you surfed the web?
Yeah, you want some--
You don't have
to land anywhere, you don't
have to commit to anything.
Just surf.
But word of advice,
wear your latex gloves.
Wear a glove, wear a
glove and go over there.
When was the last time you
used the term surfing the web
and you weren't being ironic?
I can't recall, it's
been a long time, Rhett.
It's been longer than my massage ago.
More than three months.
Right.
So there you have it.
Yeah Mythical.store.
Rep ya boys.
The reason for this episode
was we got a question
when we asked you guys to ask us anything,
a guy named John, @TheRealJohnDub
on Twitter asked us,
he said I'd love to hear you guys
discuss the trolley problem.
Okay.
And so that got us,
gave us the idea what if
we did a whole episode
where we just went through some
different ethical conundrums
starting with what I think is,
most people have probably heard of this.
They may not know what the specifics are
but you've heard of the trolley problem.
Maybe give a quick summary though.
Yeah well I'm just gonna read it.
You see a runaway trolley,
let's just say it's a train.
Well no let's say you're in San Francisco.
Well but I think the track, the tracks,
okay trolleys, the key here
is there's tracks involved.
You see a runaway trolley
moving toward five tied up
or otherwise incapacitated
people lying on the tracks.
You're standing next to
a lee-ver or a leh-ver,
whatever you prefer
that controls a switch.
If you pull the lever, the
trolley will be redirected
onto a side track and the five people
on the main track will be saved, however,
there is a single person
lying on the side track.
You have two options, do
nothing and allow the trolley
to kill the five people on the main track,
or two, pull the lever,
diverting the trolley
onto the side track where
it will kill one person.
Which is the more ethical option?
Now on its face, you may
have a knee-jerk reaction
and think that you know
what your answer would be,
but the reason that
this has been considered
a difficult ethical conundrum
or just an ethical conundrum
is because there's an
active choice being made
to kill someone that you
are responsible for--
Versus a passive choice just to sit there
and let something happen--
Yeah in other words--
You weren't technically
involved, actively involved in.
If you weren't present
and this situation just happened
in the universe somewhere,
you wouldn't be morally culpable
for anything that happened
but because you're there
and now you have the option
to pull the lever,
that's what makes it
a difficult situation.
Now, the trolley problem has been used
or referenced quite a
bit as people are trying
to program autonomous vehicles.
So self-driving cars are
being given basically programs
to be able to--
Decide.
Make these kinds of
decisions and interestingly,
most people, mosh
ethicists or most engineers
who looked at this have said
that the trolley problem
is not a great example of something
that an autonomous
vehicle needs to navigate
because it's so binary.
Basically autonomous vehicles
do not enter situations
where it's like one person or five people,
that's very uncommon.
More often there is a
range of possibilities
and even within those
binary possibilities,
there's a bunch of different
outcomes that could happen
and so it's actually way more complex
than just giving it some
trolley problem program
or however you would go
about programming the car.
But having said all that,
let's just say this is the situation.
Now typically this doesn't happen.
People don't get tied to railroad tracks
outside of cartoons usually.
Or old westerns but let's just say--
I didn't think masseuses
used latex gloves either.
That's right.
So let's just say you're
in this situation,
what would you do?
I feel like I would pull the
lever because I feel like
not doing anything is a, that's
still an act of omission.
Well the first thing
that would happen to me
if I was in this situation,
I would be like oh,
crap, I am literally in the
trolley problem right now.
I'm like what, how did I get here?
Literally this is happening,
there's five people
on this track and there's
one person on this track
and I'm right next to the lever?
That's funny but no you wouldn't.
Here's an interesting side note.
In Michael Stevens' series
on what was YouTube Red
at the time, YouTube
Premium which who knows
what it's gonna become, YouTube--
Super Premium.
Super, super--
Super time.
Nothing.
Right, it's just gonna be
nothing at some point, yeah.
Because you'd just be
in front of a paywall.
Right.
I hope Buddy System moves
in front of the paywall.
Yeah, we don't know.
We don't know
if that's gonna happen.
We hope it will.
So you may know this channel as Vsauce
but he had a series called
Mind Field with a D, Mind--
With a D.
And he actually set up, it
was like an elaborate prank--
People thought they were literally--
Slash hoax.
Yeah, yeah.
Where they were literally
lured into this trailer
and allowed to take a look at
the track switching mechanism.
Then the guy who was in
charge of it had to like,
you know--
Go to the bathroom.
Go to the bathroom or something
and then at that moment,
lookin' through the
windows or on the monitors,
he says, okay, train's
gonna kill five people
or just one person over here
and then they could either
pull the lever or not and I mean
they gave psychiatric evaluations
to these blindsided
people beforehand in order
to make sure they weren't
gonna send someone
into a catatonic state or something.
Right, yeah.
And even though they did that,
it in and of itself became
like ethically questionable
and Michael had a lot of difficulty--
Submitting people to the trolley problem
was an ethical dilemma.
Yeah.
They went through with it but man,
it's fascinating because
people were freaking out.
You know, as you would imagine.
This is not a normal thing.
It's just like,
I mean--
We typically don't have,
unless you're a doctor,
you typically don't have
people's lives in your hands.
This is an unusual
situation for most people.
I felt horrible for the
people because I mean--
Do you remember what most people did?
How they wouldn't have PTSD, I mean,
they only showed, it's not
like a legitimate sample size.
I don't know how they chose
who they put into the edit,
but everything happened.
Somebody ran out, somebody broke down,
somebody switched the
tracks, somebody didn't.
It all happened.
But they didn't have any statistics.
It wasn't like a study, it
was just a YouTube series.
Now we polled the staff here right so--
Well yeah and Kiko says there was like 12
or 14 Mythical team members who were--
Okay.
But what's your answer?
You think you would--
I would definitely pull
the lever to kill the one person.
You would kill one person
in one sense of the word,
but you would save five lives.
I don't see a lot of difference.
Because I'm there and I have the option,
my inaction will result in
the death of five people.
The whole thing about well one
is passive and one is active
in that scenario, because
it's so simple and so clean
and also I don't know the
people so I don't have,
you can complicate the trolley problem
which we'll do in a second
but an uncomplicated,
five, six strangers in that scenario,
I'm pulling the lever no questions asked.
With little to no regret.
Yeah it's like you don't know how--
I'd rather--
Psychological ramifications
there would be with either way.
Of course, I'm just saying
that I would make the decision
without regret, I'm not
saying I wouldn't suffer
from the consequences of
having killed somebody.
I'll also say that in The Good Place,
they had this entire scene
which was the trolley problem.
And it was funny.
Have you seen the movie
The Dawn Wall?
No.
You watched Free Solo.
Yes.
Alex Honnold.
There's another movie on Netflix,
it's another doc called The
Dawn Wall and it's about--
Mountain climber?
It's about these guys
who one guy in particular who was trying
to do the most difficult face,
The Dawn Wall of halftone, is that it?
It's the most difficult
climb in the entire world.
No one's ever done it.
Now he's not Free Solo,
he's tied in and it takes,
they camp up there and
it takes a long time
but it's like an impossible route.
That guy has an incredible story
and when he was 19 or 20 years old,
they went--
He operated trolleys?
No they went into, it
was like the year 2000
and they went into
somewhere in like Uzbekistan
or someplace like that
to do some crazy climbing
and this is like back
when there were sort of
the precursors to Al-Qaeda
and Isis and stuff
and there was some Islamic
fighter dudes who kidnapped them
and shot one of the people, so killed one
of the dudes so they knew
that these guys were serious
but then they were going in
circles, long story short,
this guy, one fighter,
one armed fighter ends up
going up this mountain with three of them
and so they start talking to each other
about how they just need to
push this guy off the cliff
and kill him and they're
talking in English
'cause you can't understand 'em.
And the dude pushes the guy off the cliff.
Really?
Yeah.
To save himself and his friends.
It was a huge news
thing, when he came back,
he was on The Today Show
and Good Morning America,
they were like, "So you were over there
"and you pushed this guy off the cliff?"
Anyway, it's a similar thing,
I'm gonna save my friends,
of course in that situation,
this guy has already
demonstrated that he can
and probably will kill you.
He's starting out in the wrong
so it's a little bit different.
But anyway it just made me think of--
I predict that--
I recommend that movie,
by the way.
The Mythical--
That's not my rec, I have another rec,
but I do recommend it.
I predict the Mythical team members
are gonna agree with us.
Yeah yeah yeah, I think this
one's pretty straightforward.
Okay so option, option
two is pull the lever.
Yeah yeah so option one is do nothing.
The majority of people did
say they would pull the lever.
But Lucas, Kevin, Nick and
Paisley said they wouldn't.
Wow.
Callin' 'em out.
That's an interesting group.
It's a weird--
What do those guys
have in common?
They don't have any backbone apparently.
Can't take action.
I don't know.
They're not here to, Dave
and Matthew, Kiko, Kristen,
Chase, Kaitlyn, Aubrey, Casey and Bethany,
they'd all pull the lever.
Okay well you're all right.
Now here's what I'll say.
The trolley problem--
It wasn't 100% though.
Trolley problem in my
mind isn't that difficult
of a conundrum but let's
complicate it a little.
All right.
Okay?
This is basically hinging
on the same principle
of the trolley problem but
more complex situation.
You are a doctor at a top hospital.
I don't know why it has
to be a top hospital.
You have six gravely ill patients,
five of whom are in urgent
need of organ transplants.
Okay.
You can't help them though
because there are no available organs
that can be used to save their lives.
The sixth patient, however, will die
without a particular medicine.
If he or she dies, you will be able
to save the other five
patients by using the organs
of patient six who is an organ donor.
What do you do?
Now let me just say a couple of things
before the smart-asses in the comments
start pointing things out.
I understand this is not
how organ transplants work.
You can't just take
something out of somebody
and put it into somebody
else, they have to be matches
and situations like that.
Also--
Also there aren't
really comments on podcasts.
Also well when this goes
to YouTube there are.
That's true.
Also there are legal,
let's just say you're not
working within a legal system
because there are actually laws,
in other words, at least if
you're in the United States,
you can't kill someone or let someone die
just to give organs to someone
else, you can't do that.
That's against the law so in our laws,
but let's just say that
this is the situation.
This person will save all five
people, no questions asked.
They're a match and there are no laws.
You're not gonna be
prosecuted for your decision.
But I do think the fact
that there are laws
which dictate the ethics for us,
I do think that that's revealing, right?
Because I guess to boil it
down, it's like do no harm.
Do not actively hurt somebody even
if that means saving five
times as many people.
I think the trolley problem
in its just pureness
as its initial presentation
is an easy situation,
is an easy decision for me.
This however--
But you think this is,
are you saying it's the same?
It's the same principles
but I think that there are--
Well the trolley problem is--
More complex.
Is preventing,
having the option to prevent
one of two accidents.
Which you can't prevent both.
I guess that's the same here,
you're preventing the medical
demise of these people,
it's not like, oh man.
Well a doctor can't do it.
A doctor's not allowed to do that.
But I actually feel like--
This is gonna make you feel differently.
You're gonna go back
on the trolley problem
because of this?
I don't know, what would you do?
Well the reason the trolley
problem seems easier
to me is because it is not my job...
When you're a doctor, you've
got the Hippocratic Oath right,
and so you don't get into the situation
where you're weighing patients'
lives against one another
because that quickly
gets out of hand, right?
Mm-hmm.
But the trolley problem in its pure form
doesn't get out of hand,
it's just so simple.
It's just like there's five
people, five people die
or one person dies.
Five people or one, somebody's gonna die
and the train's gonna go on either track.
It just seems so binary but
as soon as you pull back
and you get into a little bit
more of a real life situation
like this, I acknowledge it
becomes very, very difficult
to make a decision.
But let's just say you're not, okay,
a couple things can be guaranteed.
You're not gonna be prosecuted.
You know that all those people
are going to be saved and--
It's just not, there are,
you have to do the right,
I think the right thing to
do is not to harm the person.
You gotta try to give
this person the medicine,
give the one person the
medicine and help 'em
and then trust that you know what,
other people are gonna die
and maybe at the last minute
some organs are gonna swoop in.
Maybe we'll open a cabinet
and it'll be full of organs.
Whoops, forgot about that organ cabinet.
Well and that's why in the real world,
this is why you've gotta
behave exactly the way
that you just said because
you don't know what's gonna happen.
You don't have all the knowledge.
'Cause real world
situations are more complex
and things can change, but
what if these are, okay, okay,
what if these are the last six
people on the planet, okay?
These are the last six
people on the planet.
So now you can save five
or you can save one.
Is the one--
So it'd be you and one person.
A woman you can procreate with?
Let's just say you're a
man and they're all women.
I'm not trying to create
a utopian situation
for myself , I'm just saying that,
no so yeah--
This is a different
ethical question.
No no so I'm saying that
you have to repopulate
the planet, it's your job.
The burden is on you.
But you can do it with five people .
I didn't mean to walk into this situation.
It's not about procreation,
it's just about these are the
last people on the planet.
If it's not about procreation,
it's not about continuing the
species, then it's who cares?
Okay no, what if you're all going to die.
Everyone's infertile.
But either six people total
are going to continue to live
or two people are gonna continue to live.
Listen, listen.
Do the best you can to the
person who's dying the quickest
and if that's giving the
medicine, give him the medicine
and then maybe somebody
just needs a kidney.
That ain't gonna kill 'em.
Well situation--
Or and then you go
to the five people and like all right,
which one of you wants
to sacrifice yourself
in order to give your
organs to the other people?
It's like giving up an airplane seat.
Yeah it's no different.
Let it be their decision.
I would take a poll.
That's what I would do,
I'd put it back on them.
I'm just a guy with a knife.
You guys have the power.
Okay so you think it
would be ethically okay
to tell the person, listen, I
could give you this medicine
but I want you to know that if you die,
you'll save five people.
You think it's ethical
to tell that person that?
And now they're gonna be racked with guilt
the rest of their life if
they take the medicine?
I don't think you can do that either.
Well that's kind of mean but
it's not wrong, it's true.
I think they need to have a voice in it.
Let's make this even more complex.
What if this one person has the organs
to save a million people?
That can't happen, again,
it's not a real situation
but I'm saying they could
save a million people.
That's amazing.
Wow, yeah, okay.
Yeah just let 'em go.
That's a lot of people, a million people.
Yeah a million people,
this person has lots
of extra organs.
Like a million hearts.
Yeah they got all kinds of stuff.
Like cows with stomachs?
Yeah.
Is there a point in which it becomes okay?
I think it's a million, that's
a big, nice, round number.
Like half a million, oh no.
Because if you--
I think half a million.
If somebody came to you--
499,999?
No, 500,000, yes.
If somebody came to me
and they were like, you could
have saved a million people,
you could have saved 100 people.
You could have saved 1,000 people
but this one guy was
better and you know what,
it turns out this guy's an.
Not only that but he's kind of a jerk.
What if the guy you
need to get the medicine
to is 87 years old?
Yeah, I would let it be his decision.
I'm still going with that.
Things get more complex.
Even with a million.
And how do you place
worth on someone's life?
Just become worthless as they get older?
Now we're in the euthanasia situation.
Hmm, what if the person,
what if it's a million people
but then the one person
who could get the medicine
and get fully well is the
wife or like your child?
Well okay so what you've
essentially done is
take the trolley problem
but the one person
on the track is my kid, your kid.
Yeah.
What do you do now?
I don't know those five people.
What if it's my three
kids and then over here
on the other track are your two kids?
Why are you laughin'?
And who's got the lever?
You.
I'm sittin' there watching them.
And whose kids are gonna
die if I don't do anything?
We're gonna both be yanking on that lever.
I gotta work on my yanking skills.
Well okay, all right, you know what?
I gotta out-yank ya.
I got more kids than you.
Okay, all right, you know
what, I'm going to skip
to that exact question that somebody--
Oh that's an exact question?
Pretty close.
Your family's vacationing
alone on a private stretch
of beach with no lifeguard.
Your daughter--
I was just doing that.
And your niece--
Okay.
Both seven, are best friends
and eager to get into the water.
You caution them to wait
until the water calms some
but they defy you and sneak in anyway.
Oh gosh.
You soon hear screams
of distress and find them both caught--
Stop, I hate this, man.
In a strong current.
Well listen, you may be presented
with this real life conundrum and you have
to make a decision, put your Speedo on
and pull your big boy Speedo up.
You're the only strong swimmer.
You're the only swimmer
strong enough to save them
but you can only save one at a time.
Your niece is a very poor swimmer
and likely won't make it much longer.
Your daughter, however,
is a stronger swimmer
but only has a 50% chance
of holding on long enough
for you to come back for her.
Who do you save first?
Now, as I read this, I
formulated my answer.
There's a 50% chance that
you could save both of 'em.
Let's not say that, okay,
to me this seems easy.
I gotta save the one
that's a weaker swimmer.
I have to save my niece
and then hope for the best
for my daughter for a couple of reasons.
Number one, my daughter
has a better chance
of surviving on her own, my niece doesn't,
at least as presented in this situation
and you have to deal with
this decision forever
and you have to deal
with the people's opinion
about your decision
forever and it'd be like,
I sacrificed my own kid to save yours
versus I sacrificed your kid to save mine
is kind of a better legacy, right?
It's easier to live with.
It's not easy to live without
your own kid obviously
but I think that's something
you have to take into account.
But let's just say one's
not a better swimmer.
Let's just say you've
got to save one of them
and the other one is going to die.
And they're both equal swimmers,
do you save your
daughter's friend or niece
or whatever or do you save your daughter?
It's not like you're swimmin' out there
and then like a video game,
there's like a percent chance
of like their survival and data
on how well of a swimmer they are.
You're gonna swim out there,
you're gonna grab both of them.
You don't see metadata over
people's heads at all times?
No.
I do.
And then you're gonna swim out there
and you're gonna grab both
of 'em and you're gonna--
Hope for the best.
You're gonna all drown probably.
I mean I'm sorry but
that's what's gonna happen.
That's what I would do.
Grab both of them and drown?
You're not thinking logically.
All you're thinking is I've
gotta rescue these girls
and you go out there and you grab 'em
and you try to figure out a way
and it doesn't happen immediately.
So it's like, I don't
wanna talk about this.
Hold on but this is why
it's a conundrum, man.
You can't just run from the conundrum.
You have to swim out
into the middle of it.
Is it?
The fact that I don't wanna talk about it
means I'm not gonna swim
out there at all I guess.
I'm gonna swim out there, man.
I've surprised myself before.
And I would grab both of 'em.
I watched one of those John Quinones
What Would You Do situations
and they were trying to figure out
how people would intervene.
Basically the whole show's
about are you gonna intervene
in this situation and
then there's a certain,
actually a smaller percentage
than you would imagine
of people who are like heroes.
A lot of people are like,
when people do something crazy
and save a bunch of
people and they're like,
"I mean anybody would have done what I did
"in that situation."
That ain't true.
No no no.
Very few people would
have done it actually.
And it isn't necessarily
the case that the people
who make the decision to
run out and put themselves
in harm's way to save someone are
like inherently better
people, like morally
and every other way they would
be very consistently moral
and ethical in other areas of their lives.
It's just that they have something in them
that makes them not freeze
up like most people do
in those situations and
actually go into action
and solve the problem.
I don't think that I am,
I've never been presented
with this situation but I have a tendency
to think that most of
what would be driving me
in that situation is, ah I'm
gonna feel like such a jerk
if I don't do something.
But I don't think the
people who act think that,
I think they just do it.
They do it without thought.
They're doing it before it's too late.
Yeah, just on instinct.
So what would you do
when you swam out there?
I notice you just tend to
be asking the questions,
then you don't really
say what you would do.
Well I mean...
Okay, I think realistically
what I would do is like you said,
I wouldn't quickly calculate.
If I was the only person out
there and they were basically
next to each other, I would be like,
"Both of you guys grab onto me,"
and I would start trying to swim.
Now what would probably happen is,
pretty quickly I'd realize that
I can't swim in with both of them.
So I'm right back to the decision,
I have to make a decision,
I have to let someone go.
I could be like okay guys,
we're not gonna try to swim in,
we're just gonna drift, and
I would be like all right,
everybody calm down, everybody calm down.
And just breathe in
deeply, we're gonna float.
And we're gonna wait for a
lifeguard in the jet ski to come
or the coast guard or something,
we're just gonna try to float,
I'm not gonna try to save you.
I'm gonna try to create a
situation where I can prolong
my indecision for as long as possible,
so I think practically
that's what I would do,
but if it was like legitimately you've got
to make a decision, I think
I'd have to pick the one
that wasn't my kid.
Well this is so much fun,
let's just move on to another one.
Okay.
Isn't there one related to
if it were just me and you?
Let's not bring children into this.
Okay well I have a lot
much lighter hearted one.
Okay.
I thought there was one
about we're on an island
and there's a cure.
Yeah here we go, choice for the cure.
So we'll do this one.
Then we'll do the lighter hearted one.
You and your friend are
stranded on an island.
Unfortunately you're both fatally ill.
A lot of people are just fatally ill,
gravely ill in these situations.
It just so happens that
you have an antibiotic
that can cure your illness.
Sadly enough, there's
just enough antibiotic
to save only one person.
How could you and your friend choose
which one of you will take the antibiotic.
Do you think that either
person who takes it will
or should feel guilty
for the person dying,
although if neither of you
take it, you will both die?
So we both got the thing.
And somehow we know that
we can't just divide it up.
I mean, first of all I question that.
If we're out there on the island
and we're drummin' up this antibiotic--
Yeah we can't keep poking
holes in the ethical conundrums
because you're right,
they're not realistic.
Well that's what's frustrating about 'em.
I think what I would do is--
Well that's what makes
programming autonomous
vehicles so difficult
because real world conundrums
are not this, you know,
it's not just all these
little binary decisions.
It's all on a spectrum.
I would suggest that
we split the antibiotic
and hope for the best and if we both die,
I can live with that.
That's really good, did you
mean it to be that good?
Well, okay.
I never took ethics
in college.
All right, okay.
Did you?
No, I wanted to talk
about that because interestingly,
because we got engineering degrees,
now you actually ended up
taking an intro to film class
which was the most interesting
class that either of us took.
Yeah.
You decided--
It was one of
the few classes I had to write
a paper and it was horrible.
I had to write a paper about movies.
That sucks.
Really?
I just wanna watch movies or make movies.
But I've talked about this,
I was talking about this
with Jessie the other day,
I was like my college
education was so technical--
Yeah.
That it's just useless
to me now.
I wish, oh, the best class I ever took
was that future studies class.
I took a Psychology 101.
If I could go back to
college, I would just be like
what am I interested in?
That's what I wanna learn, of course,
I didn't have to use my degree
so that's a privilege that I have.
But yeah we never talked about this.
We never took an ethics class.
I didn't even take a statistics class.
You gotta take that.
I would not recommend taking
that to scratch an itch.
No but it--
I took two of those.
But it's very practical.
Uh.
It's very practical.
It gets very impractical very quickly.
Kinda like an engineering study.
We didn't talk about these things
and they make better discussion questions
than real life situations but okay,
here's a much, since you're talking
about we would split the antibiotic,
okay what if the two of us
takin' up commercial aviation.
But we're freighter,
we're freighter pilots.
Okay.
And so we're like
flying freight across the
country on a big FedEx plane,
it's just the two of
us, plane's going down.
For some reason there's
only one parachute.
You would say, you would ask me,
"Can I have the parachute?"
And I would say, "I'm a freight not."
Oh gosh.
Why would you already have the parachute?
I would already have it, trust me.
Okay first of all, do you think--
I would have it on.
Do you think we--
I'd be halfway out the door.
Here's the thing is that
you get into this situation
and you're in a panicky
situation like that,
how many best friends would you start
beating the hell out of each other
and just be like the
other guy's gonna die.
I don't think--
We would not do that.
We wouldn't do that.
We would begin to try to
evaluate, very quickly--
I'd be like, "You're taller, man."
No if it was me and--
You're probably gonna
hit the propellor when you come out.
If it was me and my dad.
Then I think my dad would be like,
"Son, you take the parachute.
"I'm 75," or however old he is.
I'd sacrifice myself for my kid,
I'd give my kid a parachute, yeah.
And I'm not just talking' about my, yeah,
I would also do it for my kid.
I think that whoever has
the most life ahead of them
or whatever, that's a good way
to sort of gauge it, right?
But if it's us--
If it's us,
even though I am taller.
You are older.
And a little bit older
which means I will die first
if it's just like natural causes.
But we won't be making
those kinds of decisions.
I think for all intents and purposes,
it's even, we each have an even claim
to the rest of our lives.
So I think we had to do--
The thing I like
about the island is that you
can have days of negotiation.
That's fun.
Okay.
At least we're having fun.
We're trying to--
Come up with some kinda competition.
Trying to figure out--
I think it has--
I think you would do
that thing we did as
kids where we'd be like
hem-hawing around in your front
yard, you'd be like, "Hey.
"You see that stop sign way over there?
"First person to take
a rock and hit the O--"
Gets the antibiotic.
I wouldn't do that.
I think we would say we have
to let the fates decide.
You'd roll the dice.
Gotta roll the dice.
I'll make the dice.
You go take a nap, I'm gonna make the di.
So rock, paper--
Just take a nap.
I'm gonna make the dice.
I'm not gonna be takin' the antibiotic.
I wouldn't even be doing--
And refilling it
with ocean water.
I don't think we should do
rock, paper, scissors
because that's a competition,
then somebody feels bad
about their gamesmanship.
It's like how do we let the
fates make this decision?
It's like picking up a palm
leaf and both throwing it up
at the same time so one
person is in control
and whichever direction it's pointing,
that's the person that
gets the antibiotic.
Flip of a coin.
A flip of a coin but
this has to be flipped
by us together.
Yeah, we're about to flip together.
Or we're just like no Link,
you get to flip the coin,
then we're both gonna
live with the results.
You can't control where a coin lands.
The fates have decided.
Then that's the comedy
because I flipped the coin
and it goes in a hole,
it goes in a snake hole.
There's snakes on this island?
Yeah and then we gotta dig out the--
I don't wanna live.
And then we're like
we wanna dig out the hole in order to see,
but you gotta dig it out in such a way
to see how it landed and
then a snake comes out
and bites you and then I'm like hey man,
not only do you have that other illness,
now you've been bitten by a snake
so give him the antibiotic.
If we were in the parachute thing,
to me that's easier, I think again,
I'm the middle ground man.
I think what we would
do is, you're bigger.
You'd wear the parachute, okay?
You want me to hold onto you?
And then I'm gonna latch
onto you like a baby monkey.
I'm gonna put my legs inside of the straps
and I'm gonna put my
arms inside the straps
and I'm gonna latch onto you.
All your joints will dislocate as soon
as I pull the cord, man.
No they won't.
Me holdin' onto you,
I'm just as strong as a,
fine, I'll wear the parachute
and you latch onto me.
What would happen if two people were
on one parachute though?
I mean I know tandem happens all the time
but that's like a special chute, right?
No, I don't think so.
Yeah we both, you're right though.
I mean I wear a belt at all times
so I could probably somehow
strap myself in via belt.
Or I take my jeans off and tie myself in
so I'd be naked but strapped in.
I don't want you to be naked.
I have underwear on.
I want you to have clothes on.
I wanna live, man.
But you're right, that
is what we would do.
But if we're on the island,
there's no arguments that we'd be making.
Like well, I have more kids
to support than you do.
I'd make that argument.
Yeah but I don't think that stands.
More immediate family members would be sad
to see me leave than you.
You can't get into, I think the only thing
that seems like a fair
negotiation tactic is
how much life you have to live.
But judging the worth
of your current life--
It just gets into some gray areas.
So what would you do about the antibiotic?
You would flip a coin.
I would flip a coin.
Yeah yeah.
We'd flip a coin.
Let's ask--
This is the opening scene
of our movie, by the way.
We're both dying and
only one of us can live
and we flip a coin and it
goes into a snake hole.
And then the rest of
the movie's just digging
into that snake hole?
It's a short film.
Yeah it's a short film.
I'm gonna ask this one
that is a little bit less
of a life or death situation.
We've actually talked
about something like this.
Every day you commute, your
commute back home requires you
to exit from a two lane
road onto a freeway.
To do so, you must--
Read it with more energy.
I mean it's already boring, at
least try to make it sound--
Every day your commute
back home requires you
to exit from a two lane
road onto a freeway.
Wow.
To do so, you must be--
I would call that
merge onto--
In the right lane,
but that right lane
backs up for two miles,
adding 20 minutes to your daily commute.
You're tempted to stay in the left lane
which moves much more
quickly and then right before
the freeway on ramp, cut ahead of the cars
that have been waiting for the 20 minutes.
Do you cut in?
We do this every day, first of all.
The way that we go
home, we encounter this.
Yep yep yep yep yep.
So I mean--
Not coming to work but going home.
I'm offended by this question
because I think it sets me up to be bad.
Well okay so we talked--
I slide in
at the last second, you know why?
Because at the last
second, that's when people,
they loosen up.
Oh they think oh, I'm
through with this merge.
I can take my time, I don't have
to be right behind the
person in front of me
and they leave a gap.
And so nobody loses.
Well--
Well maybe they
put on brakes.
In one sense, your behavior
is creating a longer line
but you're actually contributing
to the problem that you're avoiding
which is not a great ethical place to be.
However...
Right.
I would do the same thing.
But I do it based on the
principle that we talked about
on Ear Biscuits before
which is that the proper way
and the way that autonomous
vehicles will merge
when they're all
autonomous is they'll do it
in a zipper fashion--
Yeah but that's--
They'll fold on--
Hold on,
that's not what's happening here.
One after another.
This is not two lanes
coming into one lane and the
thing that we actually do
where it's like you got a
freeway and then an exit,
to then go on an overpass
onto another freeway.
And you can either be
in the far right lane
which backs up--
Oh you're right.
Or you can be one lane over.
You're right.
So it never--
It's not losing a lane.
You're right, you're right,
it's just everybody's got
to funnel into someplace.
You risk someone not letting you in
and then you're sitting there
in the median like a chump
and then you pay the consequences.
Okay.
I'm willing to pay those consequences,
one out of every 20 times.
This might reveal something about me.
That, but I'm just being vulnerable.
I do it and as I'm doing
it, I think to myself,
you know what, a lot of people
are just not comfortable
with the uncertainty and
the tension that is created
with getting in at the last
second but you know what,
I am comfortable with that ,
so all these people who are backed up,
they just want to get in
and avoid this situation
that I am voluntarily
inserting myself into,
this chaotic, last minute--
They don't have the guts--
Decision.
To take the risk.
That's what I'm actually thinking
without even really processing
it even though I know
that the reality is these
people are just nice
and I'm an, .
Because only an, would
think that he's actually
embracing chaos and
these people are afraid.
Jenna's over here laughing.
Do you get in--
Do you do that?
Oh you get in the line?
And how do you feel
about the people like us?
Are you avoiding chaos?
She said--
You get mad.
She said we're.
No, I'm not having a rough day,
I'm just having another day.
I'm going home like I always do.
Yeah and we got people waitin' for us.
We got kids waitin' for us.
I'm passing a bunch--
Yeah we're dads.
Single people, they
don't have to see anybody
except a dog or whatever.
Jenna's laughing.
I don't have to see
Jenna out of the corner
of my eye the whole time
we're doing the podcast.
Get that judgment.
That judgment hits the back of my head,
not to the side of my eye.
Okay so we just concluded--
I think the problem,
the real test of that is if
everybody did what we did,
what would happen and
a lane that is supposed
to be like a 65 mile per hour freeway lane
becomes a second off-ramp lane.
That ain't how it's supposed to be.
Yeah, right.
Matter of fact, we can
counter this twice going home.
And that's why I don't have
the patience to do that twice,
to sit in that long line
and just quote mellow out.
Yeah you're right,
getting on both interchanges
is what happens.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't know, I'll think
differently about it
as I'm driving today.
I'll do the same though.
Right.
I will think differently.
Okay one last one that I
think is also practical.
This is something that we
can't personally relate to
but it actually makes me think of an idea
I recently pitched to my wife
and I'll pitch it to everyone.
You're on a dating website.
Is it ever ethical to make yourself
seem younger than you are?
You're older, you've
been single a long time
and you're lonely.
You're frustrated that it seems
that all the good
potential romantic partners
want someone younger.
You think if only they'd give me a chance,
they'd see I bring a lot to a relationship
even if I have wrinkles.
So you're wondering,
this is very specific,
so you're wondering if like many people,
your profile should say
you're younger than you are
and include only a distant photo
so your age isn't as apparent.
What would you do?
So lying about your age, eh, okay.
That feels like that's a
situation you can't back out of
if you're looking for any
more than just a hookup.
No I think that's a great
way to start a lasting,
healthy relationship.
But let's just say,
what do you think about,
and again, we don't use
dating apps, never have.
We got married before
any of this was a thing.
But people deceive
purposely on their profile.
They exaggerate, they only show pictures
where they look good, right,
they only show pictures
of their good side or their
good angle or whatever.
Let me just pitch an idea to you because
this whole process seems very deceptive.
And I think that this technology
for this exists.
I told Jessie there should be a dating app
where the only picture
is, you open up the app,
you take a picture,
you turn the camera on,
you do a video of your head
like this, all around--
360 stand.
And then you do
a video like this.
Vertically and horizontal.
And then you enter into a
program that then creates
a perfect 3D model of what
you actually look like
and then the person who
looks at your profile,
there's no swiping or anything,
it's a augmented reality,
it's AR where--
They kiss it.
You can put the camera
up there, your phone
and you move your phone around
and it's like you're looking
at the person in space.
Okay whoa, weak chin, oh, weak chin.
Or like whoa, whoa,
look at, so you know exactly
and the name is the dating app is Shallow.
That's my pitch.
Exactly.
No seriously, that's it, that's my pitch.
Anybody wants to invest in this.
All it is is a augmented
reality interactive picture
of a person's face.
Literally you don't even know their name,
no stats about them, you
don't know their age,
your decision is based completely
on what they actually
look like in real life
and it's called Shallow.
Listen based on what you--
I'm taking investors.
Based on what you just told me,
if you hadn't already told
me about how you drive,
I would now know.
Okay?
No it's just an idea for a dating app.
It's authentically--
Shallow.
Presenting yourself
but it's like, listen, it's
all about what you look like.
I got a better idea.
What do you think about my idea?
I don't like it, I have a better one.
Okay.
You can use this on any dating app
and I don't need any investment.
You post a picture, a split
screen or two pictures
and you're like this is me
going out on a date with you,
first date look.
And this is me staying in like,
I don't expect to see anybody.
Not even going out to get the mail.
And it's like, if you
wanna get into physicality,
go ahead and take care of
it, say this is my spectrum.
This is my hottest and this is my nottest.
But here's the thing though.
People can still deceive within that.
'Cause what you do is
you set up one of those,
what do you call it that's a
candid shot that's a plandid.
You know that's the word that
people are throwing out now,
plandid.
Oh I haven't heard that.
This is what's happening on Instagram
where it's a planned candid shot.
Yeah you're right.
So people would be like--
It's easy to fake that.
Look at me in my little PJs.
This is me not going out.
I look so gross.
Right.
But you're seeing my good
side, you know what I'm saying?
All right we need,
I want a 3D scan that
includes personality, man.
Okay, all right, all right, maybe we can--
It is shallow.
Maybe we can incorporate
the 3D AR technology into a
more comprehensive dating app
that takes into account things
other than physical appearance.
I just thought if you really
wanted to make a decision
based on what somebody looks like,
'cause that is a big part
of the initial thing,
you don't then make a decision of whether
or not you're gonna continue
dating based on that,
but a lot of it's kinda
based on that initially.
I'm just saying, in fact, Tinder
or whatever the other
ones are, talk to me.
Let's incorporate this into your app.
I think you need to create
a Tinder account first.
And this whole idea of being able
to actually see what somebody looks like
because when you get there and
you meet at the coffee shop,
you're gonna be--
You're gonna be swipin'
with your head around.
You're gonna see
every angle, man.
Be swimmin'
and swipin' your--
You can't maintain your--
Noggin.
You can't maintain
your good side, this angle
during the whole conversation.
You don't do that, you can try.
But eventually they're gonna see
the other side of your face.
And they've gotta deal with the reality.
In other words, I do think--
You shouldn't lie
about your age.
It's ethically wrong to lie,
definitely lie about your age,
your job, any of that stuff.
But I think that it's
a gray area ethically
to lie about the way you look.
I mean you wanna put
your best foot forward.
But you gotta drag that other
foot along for the ride.
You gotta put your bad foot
out there too.
Yeah that's right.
'Cause you're attached to it.
Quite literally.
I think I've learned,
ethics are oversimplified.
They're constructs to help you think--
Yeah.
Of things that then
in the real world,
you're either just acting
on instinct or probably
choosing the wrong thing.
To me the biggest ethical
premise that I live by is
act quick and apologize often.
Mm-hmm.
I should have saved my
niece but I don't know,
I was just swimmin' fast and
my daughter was right there.
Sorry.
Mm.
Ouch.
Wow.
Tried to put it in context--
Don't let your niece listen to this.
Do you have a niece?
I don't have a niece.
I got nervous, I was almost
gonna say I don't have a niece,
then I'm like hold on, do I have a niece?
I have a half-niece.
Okay well, I think we've solved--
Is that a thing?
It's a thing.
Yeah you can have a half-niece.
I have a half-sister, she's got daughters.
I got a half-niece.
Oh yeah you do have half-nieces.
Yeah.
Don't go swimmin' with them.
We did go to the beach once.
Really?
Yeah we went swimmin'.
Glad they didn't know that you thought
this way about them.
Well I think the worst thing
is it seems like I forgot
they existed for a second.
I definitely wouldn't save 'em.
I didn't know they were around.
Well I've only met them once.
One time.
I've only met 'em once.
Yeah, yeah, you don't
have to apologize to me.
Okay.
That's what I said,
talk a lot, apologize most of the time.
All right, I have a--
Oh lord.
Do you have
anything else ethical?
No.
Because I have a rec
that I'm excited about.
Let's move onto recommendations man,
'cause this ethics has
made my head explode.
Trying to be good and right, that's hard.
Now, this actually would
have been a better rec
for our previous episode about the secret
to long-term marriage.
Okay.
Because I'm making a music rec
and I'm making a music rec,
there's an interesting story
that goes along with this
because I was in the
process of creating my,
it's business-time program,
that involves lights changing.
We remember.
And a certain playlist.
Let me just say, for those of
you who like to have sound,
like to have musical accompaniment
to your mail sorting,
I think is the term that
we used in the past,
if you enjoy sorting the mail
with your significant other
and you like to do that to
a soundtrack of some kind,
as I do, as my wife does...
What I found on Spotify, Apple, regardless
of the music service, the playlists
that people have come up
with for mail sorting--
Mm-hmm.
Are inadequate
and they don't align
with my personal taste.
It's just you're like
oh this is a good one.
Everything's going right, then
all of a sudden you're like,
why'd you put this one in there?
You've ruined it for us.
Too much conga.
And so, I was like I have
to engineer my own playlist
that fits my wife and I's vibe.
And I--
Don't want an impotent playlist.
And the process of building this playlist,
I happened upon an artist
I was not familiar with
named Mac Ayres, M-A-C
A-Y-R-E-S.
Young guy from New York
who's got a couple albums
and it's just this funky,
soulful, it's baby-making music.
And in fact, he was called
the king of baby-making music
by somebody like Billboard or somebody.
There was an article about it.
You know how Billboard
likes to make babies.
And this guy is really, really incredible.
Now I added many of his
songs to the playlist.
I have like a 50 song playlist
and I think Mac's got 10 songs on there.
That's wishful thinking
if I've ever heard of it.
50 song playlist.
I'm not saying I'm gonna go for 50 songs.
I shuffle the list so you never
know what you're gonna get.
There's some Rihanna on there.
That's a ethical conundrum.
And so you never know which,
I don't wanna be repeating
myself in any way,
shape or form, I just want the
lights to be red every time.
God, the lights turn red?
Well I mean--
Red light special.
We're dialing in the color of the lights.
Yeah, red--
Well there's a reason red .
Try it, have you tried it?
Well, do I need to sign up
to use your bedroom or something?
Well you can have one of my bulbs.
Or you could buy your own.
I'd like to reserve a slot in your--
So I find this guy, very impressed,
and Jessie's very into it,
I was like oh that's good.
Move on.
No she's very into the music.
And the whole family by the way.
I didn't tell the kids why
I got to know this guy,
the whole family likes this guy.
He's got a cool vibe, I
didn't say oh it's for,
the reason you're here,
it's the reason we like,
I didn't say any of that.
I follow this guy on Twitter.
It's like playing Barry
White and you're like,
for your bar mitzvah or something.
I start following Mac on Twitter.
He immediately follows me back.
Oh he immediately follows you back.
Messages me and says, "Man.
"I'm a Mythical Beast."
What?
He's like, "I've been a fan
since I was in middle school."
He was like, "I had the
Mythical shoes and everything."
What?
So Mac,
Mythical Beast Ayres, king of--
♪ Return of the mac ♪
King of baby-making music
is a Mythical Beast.
Does he have any children?
Well he's responsible for a lot.
He probably needs to
be paying child support
to a lot of people.
Just because his music is so effective.
Anyway, highly recommend Mac,
not just for baby-making
music, just for good vibes.
And also because he's a fan of ours.
But he's a good guy, at
least he's got great taste
in internet comedy and
he's a talented musician,
up and coming guy, think he's like 22.
Take a listen, follow him on Spotify.
Up and Coming, that's the
name of his latest album.
Oh wow.
I'll tell ya man.
No that's just what you do
in response to his music.
Hey you don't have to spell it out.
Okay all right, okay, okay!
When I make a good zinger, just--
Okay, all right, okay, all right.
Just let it.
Okay, all right, got it.
Just let it lay, man.
Shout out to Mac.
Rec in Effect.
There's your rec.
#EarBiscuits.
Boy, I'm glad you're still here.
It's like--
Boy.
You coulda,
there's so many points
you could have left,
like talking about killing nieces.
You should have seen the original list,
when we were doing the
research on this it was like,
that was like some morbid stuff.
I was like I can't take this.
And Rhett was like, "No,
that's the greatest."
I mean the ones that we didn't talk about,
the ethical conundrums floating
around on the internet.
Well you know what if you wanna--
Downright nasty.
If you wanna talk about
some more, there's a
lot of these available.
There's a lot more to talk
about, we didn't get into
some of the even grittier ones.
But I'm willing to go there.
Let us know, let us know if
you wanna hear more about this.
#EarBiscuits.
All right, we'll speak at you next week.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.